superman is an american icon and while
the character is criticized for not
being as edgy as some of his super
colleagues
not just anyone can play him for truth
justice and hollywood way
here are our thoughts on the best and
worst choices for actors to replace
henry cavill as superman
best matt bomer white collar's matt
bomer was considered an early candidate
for man of steel
and he actually voiced the alien
superhero that year in superman unbound
before that bomer was cast as superman
before brandon ralph
in what eventually became superman
returns according to huffpost
the same year bomer publicly came out as
gay at an awards ceremony
author jackie collins claimed that he
was ousted from the role because of it
undoubtedly bomer has the looks and the
acting chops to play superman
plus he's already been cast as superman
twice
worst nicholas cage believe it or not a
growing number of people want nicholas
cage to get another shot at the role of
the last son of krypton
cage was famously cast in tim burton's
superman lives
which was never finished because well
sometimes the universe is kind
let's be honest cage is too old warner
brothers probably wants people to
actually go see their new superman
movies
and unless they're planning a
non-traditional dystopian superman film
superman is not insane best
army hammer one of the names that's
coming up more than others is cavill's
man from uncle co-star armie hammer
he was cast as batman in george miller's
unrealized justice league mortal and
according to the hollywood reporter's
blog heat vision he was also one of the
final contenders for man of steel
superman role before it went to cavil
hammer would be a perfect fit he's got
the height he's got the physique
and as proven by the well-deserved
praise for his work in 2017's call me by
your name
he's got the talent worst john krasinski
even though john krasinski isn't at the
top of a lot of list to replace cavill
mark hughes of forbes thinks he's a
perfect choice perhaps it's the product
of typecasting but it's difficult to
imagine krazynski is superman hughes
comparison of krazynski's character on
the office to clark kent is more than
apt
and that's the problem it isn't
difficult at all to see krazynski as
kent
but it feels almost impossible to see
him portraying the other half of that
iconic duality
his work in a quiet place and jack ryan
notwithstanding
krzezinski seems like the guy who plays
the one who's being saved
not the one who's doing the saving best
michael b jordan it didn't take long at
all for reports to surface that warner
brothers already had a front-runner to
replace cavill as superman
and if it pans out it would arguably be
the most non-traditional and bold
superman casting choice to date
black panther's michael b jordan
continuously proving himself to be a
stellar actor with huge range
jordan's one of the premier reasons
black panther is an oscar contender
and as anyone who's had to hear their
partner talk about jordan going
shirtless can attest
we know he's got the physique worst
dwayne johnson
the rock's name is popping up as a
potential candidate for obvious reasons
he sells tickets he's got the body for
it and as usa today said
he is superman after all however dwayne
johnson's commitments to play the
anti-hero black adam would make playing
superman in the same narrative difficult
and while superman is big muscular and
larger than life just like johnson
he's also extremely humble and johnson
just may not be that guy
in fact if warner brothers decided to go
in a different physical direction for
superman's classic nemesis
johnson could make a great lex luthor he
already has the hairdo
best colin o'donoghue according to the
hollywood reporters blog heat vision
once upon a times colin o'donoghue was
one of the actors competing with cavill
for the role of superman
in 2013's man of steel the irish post
reported that o'donoghue is now an early
front-runner to replace him
o'donohue is a good choice but not a
perfect one
he certainly has the acting ability and
the looks to play superman but he also
has a natural mischievous quality that
you wouldn't ordinarily associate
with a man of steel while he would do
well in superman's tights
you'd almost wonder if he might do
better in lex luthor's office
worst tyler heckland dc comic fans were
thrilled when tyler hecklin appeared as
superman in the second season of
supergirl
and many arrowverse viewers seem
convinced this is the perfect job for
him
but whether or not you like heclin's
take on the man of steel
someone already playing superman and
another live action medium with a
different storyline
should not be the guy who replaces
cavill having two
live-action supermen played by two
different men is probably confusing
enough
casting the same guy in both roles
forget it
best henry golding crazy rich asian star
henry
golding has emerged as one of the
leading contenders to play superman in
any future dceu
projects and the choice is promise he's
a rising star in hollywood with good
looks and a warm likeability
mandy's getting a lot of attention right
now add to that the fact that warner
brothers has been making some very
public statements recently about their
commitment to diversity
and goldin seems like he has a real shot
at those blue tights if he wants them
worst rob delaney comedian rob delaney
jokingly threw his hat in the ring for
the new superman the same day it was
reported that cavill was out
tweeting heard there in the market for a
new superman how sexy are they looking
to go
while delaney's deadpool 2 role
certainly highlighted his flying skills
it's highly unlikely that he's a serious
contender still
it would almost be worth hearing
deadpool complain about warner brothers
poaching the comedian from his franchise
if all it meant was enduring delaney's
superman for a film or two